you know Hollywood has a history of
trying things that are out of the beauty
box Steven Gordon as far as getting
stung by bees
they use the stinger remove from the
beat or they allow the bee to sting you
and it does hurt anything that causes a
little bit of swelling and inflammation
can make you look dewy and pretty for a
while because you're a little swollen
just enough but the risk is epic because
there's a chance of anaphylactic
reaction and another way to help boost
collagen you stick these leeches onto
your abdomen and then or maybe your face
then you take it off and you smear the
blood all over your face but if that's
all too extreme for you fear not we
teamed up with rock skincare and their
subs woman dr. Guan che to bring you an
accessible anti-aging routine
I recommend ROC retinol correction max
daily hydration anti-aging cream it
contains two of my favorite active
ingredients it has retinol which helps
with wrinkles and hyaluronic acid which
we know is a great moisturizer and what
kind of results have you seen it
delivers 24-hour hydration and is
clinically proven to visibly reduce
wrinkles in one week where can we get it
we can get it at Walmart and it's less
than $25 a lot more affordable than some
of the procedures we've been talking
about I've already got it on order you
what a big difference costs mother my
face